well virtually all of official
Washington Republicans and Democrats
have united behind the idea that the
United States has a moral obligation to
go deeper into war in Syria we already
have thousands of troops in Syria that
you wouldn't know it from watching the
other robert muller based channels
they're all stormy Daniels all the time
but it's true we do and one American
soldiers already died in Syria we've
killed hundreds of Russian citizens so
far there and lobbed in a series of
cruise missiles but that's not enough
the pundits say we need a real war
something big and deadly primarily to
avenge the Syrian President Assad's
poison gas attack on his own citizens
over the weekend here's some of the
growing consensus on that Assad and his
inner circle should be considered war
criminals legitimate military targets if
you have the opportunity to take him out
you should it's very clear to me that
this president after using such rhetoric
on Sunday has to take strong stronger
military action than we did last year we
have a leader who is now a war criminal
supported by the Iranians and the
Russians that demands a strong and risky
response if the West won't stand up when
a leader uses gas multiple times against
his own people we live in a very
dangerous world so that's the consensus
last night we asked the obvious
questions about it before we go to war
are we sure all of this is real do we
really know that Assad was behind the
gas attack it's not a defensive Assad
but it's an obvious question how could
we know that conclusively so soon after
the attack happened we didn't have any
Americans on the ground
and why would I saw do that given the
certainty it would hurt his own
interests and while we're on the subject
by the way why is a war in Syria a good
idea for the United States in the first
place how would it make us safer happier
more prosperous those seem like
reasonable questions to us in fact the
exact questions you'd want your
policymakers to ask but no they're not
asking them and they're offended to hear
them the first person we ask those
questions to Republican senator Roger
wicker of Mississippi implied that we
were somehow allied with Vladimir Putin
just for asking
other than that wicker had no answers at
all it was embarrassing it he didn't
seem embarrassed at all others just
denounced us right off the top Jennifer
Rubin of the Washington Post tweeted
this quote he is insane
meaning me fox is not a news
organization that is all
no Rothman of commentary called the show
quote nothing less than undiluted
Russian propaganda
Seth Mendel the New York Post summarized
the criticism perfectly when he tweeted
this very simply shut the F up
these are journalists by the way an
explanation of course shutting the eff
up is the whole point of tweets like
that they wants you to be quiet and want
you to do what you're told don't want
questions shut up and obey there's no
chance of that though sorry Glenn
Greenwald has been following all of this
he's an founding editor at the intercept
and he joins us tonight so Glenn you
know leaving aside the real question of
how you should respond to Syria and is
it a threat to the world order and to us
and to its neighbors I think those are
all fair questions but why the universal
attempt in the meeting here in this
country left and right to shut down a
meaningful conversation about it the
only time I think that the media praised
Donald Trump was almost one year ago
today when he bombed an airfield in
Syria in response to what had been
alleged at the time was an accountable
attack by the Assad regime
people who hate Donald Trump and go on
air every day took a break for 24 hours
to proclaim him presidential because
that's what US presidents and their eyes
do is they just drop bombs on other
countries with no declaration of war no
reason why the US interest or the u.s.
borders are at stake when it happens so
I think that's just the ethos in
Washington that not only is it just an
inherently good and presidential thing
to do to drop bombs on other countries
that's why polls around the world show
that the greatest threat to world peace
on the eyes of the public in around the
world is the United States but also you
know Adam Smith wrote three hundred
years ago that the reason people who
live in capitals and in the elites and
countries love to watch their countries
bomb other countries is because it gives
them sense of excitement and purpose and
kind of this pulsating stimulation and
they think that's a really big part of
it it doesn't matter whether it'll
accomplish anything it just makes us
feel strong and powerful and purposeful
to do and so just bombs away I think
that's right I mean I think human nature
explains a lot of this I agree
completely but journalists exist to push
back against that not necessarily
against war but against
heedless rushed toward anything I mean
our job is to be skeptical and ask real
questions why is no one doing that and
anyone who does is attacked so you know
just about every name that you mentioned
in the media who who attacked you for
raising questions about whether or not
we ought to actually go in another
country are all essentially neo-cons the
the same people who were doing this in
2002 and 2003 saying anyone who asked
questions about whether we should
actually go to war and remove Saddam
Hussein a little bit was a mirror of the
Saddam regime they did the same in 2011
when it came time to remove Gaddafi they
said if you're against that war it means
you love Gadhafi and you want to see him
slaughter people it's just the standard
tactic and what we have now is this kind
of union between neo-cons who who have
now once again kind of been embraced by
both the establishment wings of the
Republican and Democratic Party and the
militarist and Bowl party people like
Lindsey Graham and lots of Democrats who
love every single war and so this
climate arises that you're just supposed
to cheer when it comes time to drop
bombs on other countries not ask whether
there's evidence to justify it not ask
whether it will do any good not ask
whether it will kill any civilians and
if you do ask those questions it means
you're on the side of America's enemies
it's an incredibly authoritarian tactic
that gets used to suppress debate yeah
it's poison I agree Glenn Greenwald
thank you as always